my manager got a call checking on my my
availability for it and he called me and
he said I got a call about this movie
it's the Barbie movie Greta garbage
directing it Marco Robbie and Ryan
goslinger starring in it and it's
filming in London for four months or
something so I told them you probably
wouldn't want to do it because you
probably don't want to go to London I
was like what what do you mean call them
back
[Music]
super bad
is an imaginary number it doesn't really
exist
if I equals it was sort of this like
long audition process I felt I had to
keep proving myself I I mean nobody they
were kind of it was kind I guess felt
like it was going in a good direction
that they felt kept bringing me back but
actually the way I found out I got the
part was from Jonah one day I got a
voicemail from Jonah saying hey we're
gonna do this movie together so we we
have to hang out Judd says we have to
hang out and that was really how I found
out I got the movie and that Jonah was
going to be in it and I was so excited
that it was going to be him because you
know he hadn't sort of occurred to me as
someone who could play that part but
when I found out it was going to be him
I really felt like it was going to be a
great movie because I had done a couple
table reads with Jonah actually for
other projects and Jonah was just always
like astoundingly great at them and he
would be one of those guys sometimes
said they would throw a couple parts at
you know like you do you do a handful of
Parts every single thing that they threw
at him he would like make you know so
interesting and so much more interesting
than it was it would just be a very flat
thing and he would bring so much
character to it so I knew how great he
was and was very excited to get to do
that movie with him
I should buy Becca alcohol yeah I'm
gonna repair that way you know she'll be
drunk you know when you hear a girl
saying like oh so shit-faced last night
I shouldn't have that guy we
could be that mistake Jonah and I are
friends to this day and I think we just
are naturally friends I mean it's up to
you Fogle this guy's either going to
think here's another kid with a fake ID
or here's McLovin the 25 year old
Hawaiian organ donor okay so what's it
gonna be
I am McLovin
no you're not no one's big loving
mclovin's never existed because that's a
made-up dumb fairy tale name you
when we made the movie I think it
cost like 20 million dollars to make and
so it didn't feel like a small movie to
me I mean it already felt like the
biggest thing that had ever happened to
me just getting the job
and getting to make it so it kind of
felt to me like a bit of a given that it
would be a big movie or else it would
have been a big failure it was so
popular and I was so recognizable
suddenly and so were all of us and it's
a strange adjustment to make you know
but it was kind of helpful to do it all
together and we sort of just had our
heads down and we're going on this like
giant press tour and it all just felt
like this big you know tumble dry cycle
of craziness it's helpful to go through
it together and
figure it out as we went
Scott Pilgrim Vs the World
[Music]
on my mind
can't wait to hear when it's finished I
was such a fan of Edgars from
space and Sean of the dead and um Hot
Fuzz well Edgar actually had visited the
set of Arrested Development and was
friends with with I think with David and
Jason and will and I didn't get a chance
to meet him when he came and I was kind
of disappointed but when I just you know
when Edgar reached out when I was even
just in contact with him I was really
excited because I was a big fan I knew
he was incredibly talented it was
exciting to me it was sort of like too
good to be true because I also loved the
graphic novels it just felt like
fortunate to be the right age the right
time yeah it just it was a lucky thing
[Music]
thank you
it was so much fun it was a long shoot I
think I mean for me in particular
because other people kind of came and
went you know but I was there for I
think nine months or something which is
like an enormous amount of time to work
on something but it was so much fun all
the time because we just had the
greatest Vibe with everybody I think
that basically trickled down from Edgar
and the energy that he was creating and
we all got to rehearse together and
spend a lot of time together before we
even started making the movie by the end
of the movie I felt like this is this is
my world this is my group of friends it
kind of feels like oh this is always
going to be this way and I honestly I
kind of was a little depressed when we
were done because um
you know it all just goes away and uh
you're like where did everybody go you
know so you kind of get used to that as
you get older and as you're reacting for
a while but I was sad to lose it I could
have kept making that forever even
though it was exhausting
we were kind of doing like endurance
training more than anything more than
like bodybuilding or something and and
like fight training you know
choreography which is just so unnatural
to me and sometimes hurt there were a
couple times where I got hurt you know
like I just even like blocking a kit you
know trying to a block over and over and
find the right like point in space to
put your hand and one time I just went
too low and received the full blow of
this guy's kick one of the stuntman who
was just kicking at a point in air and
it's it's an insane feeling you can't
believe it's happening in your hand like
you didn't know that you had these
muscles in your hand now they're
throbbing for like a week like a train
hit me in the hand you know it it's very
weird
arrests of development
the thing is that before the year before
Arrested Development I had done a sitcom
that never aired called the grubs which
was a fox multicam sitcom sorry Randy
Quaid and Carol Kane you know it sort of
it just didn't it never aired they we
shot Eight Episodes of it it was maybe
sort of formulaic like family
Dysfunctional Family
sitcom it was really funny it was
written by really funny writers but it
was sort of situational and I was
playing sort of a stock you know teenage
part maybe and then when I got the role
in Arrested Development and had this
whole storyline that was really insane
of being in love with my secretly in
love with my first cousin I should go to
my mom tonight and be like I met the
cutest guy and then she'll see you and
me totally making out yeah
but not really right I just remember
being really grateful as a kid to have
such a strange
through line storyline in a show as a
kid because I feel like Teenage roles
and TV shows are sort of stock and you
don't get too much to sink your teeth
into other than being precocious or
being whatever so I was I was excited
about that and um and it saw a lot of
humor in it and you know I just thought
it was always really so funnily handled
that Jason Bateman is just completely
oblivious to it you stay on top of her
buddy
do not be afraid to ride her
heart
[Music]
I was just so excited to be a part of
such a great troop of actors too and be
around these people all the time was was
the greatest thing do you know the last
time that I made love to my wife no I'll
tell you when no don't see nothing has
ever been easy for us I mean the only
reason she went out with me was to piss
off her boyfriend the only reason she
ever married me was to piss off her
mother
and then of course we couldn't conceive
so there was that famous ordeal what do
you mean you couldn't conceive but was
maybe adopted what she not really
related to me is she just some girl I
know I was really excited when they
started writing sort of these Side Story
lines that involved myself and David
Cross like having one-on-one scenes
together because I loved David and I
worshiped David actually before Ever
Getting to meet him or work with him
because I watched Mr show Growing Up
where I grew up every Friday night there
was the Tom Green Show and Mr show
slotted as an hour and and me and my
friend watched it like religiously so
when I heard David was potentially going
to be in the pilot I was like incredibly
excited and then they started writing
scenes with with David and I when he
becomes kind of my roommate on we're
like sharing the bunk bed at some point
in one of the earlier seasons and those
were always so much fun to film and
really hard for me to keep it together I
have to wear it all the time you'd never
understand oh please I'll never
I'll never understand that you can never
be nude
I understand more than you
never know
yeah it was completely intimidating they
were completely encouraging and
supportive with me and Alia who's my
cousin on the show who you know we were
the two children on the show and it's
like it just is intimidating because
they're all operating on this insanely
high level of intellect and humor and
they're so fast and they're so brilliant
but even though it was intimidating I
feel like we just benefited enormously
by getting to be around it and soak them
up and be part of it and just you know
be part of the fun that they were
creating
Barbie
it was a kind of very last minute
casting my manager got a call checking
on my my availability for it and he
called me and he said I got a call about
this movie it's the Barbie movie Greta
was directing it and it's filming in
London for you know four months or
something so I told them you probably
wouldn't want to do it because you
probably don't want to go to London and
I was like what
do you mean call them back I mean he
didn't like like blow it or anything but
he's like I manage their expectations
that you might not want to do and I was
like how can I not do it it's like I
need to do it so I somehow got Greta's
email address I think through a common
friend of ours and I emailed her I was
like can I be can I do that part and she
was like let's get on a zoom right now
here's here's a zoom link I'll be on
there for the next hour
so she was just hanging out on the zoom
she's like just click that link whenever
you're ready and then we talked about it
and it just all happened really fast
from there hi Barbie
oh hi Alan there are no multiples of
Alan he's just Alan yeah
I'm confused about that I mean Alan is a
sad you know pers figure he's just a
person that just doesn't really have any
place in the world you know Alan is
actually based on a real doll that
enjoyed a very short production run I
think like the year 1967.
it just wasn't selling I think the world
the world just didn't need to for Ken to
have a friend like to supplement that
wing of the collection it was like
Barbie is good we can get a lot more
Barbies in here and friends of hers but
we've got Ken and we don't need to go
deeper in that direction he can hold it
down so Alan kind of you know fell by
the wayside a little bit
honestly there's been so much
anticipation for the movie ever since it
was even we even started working on it I
think it's just very infectious maybe
there's just something in the world
right now that people are ready for a
Barbie movie they just it feels like
just the right time they have a Barbie
movie I mean even on the set everything
was very infectious everybody was
wearing pink shoelaces and everything
and
it was fun it was it was a good spirit
right from the start
Juno
[Music]
what should we do
that
well you know I was just
I was thinking I'd just nip it in the
bud before it gets worse because they
were talking about health class how
pregnancy
it can often lead to an infant
typically yeah yeah that's that's what
happens when our moms and teachers get
pregnant when I read the script the
first time the thing that like really
grabs you is the rhythm of it and the
dialogue
so you're cool with that then
yeah yeah wizard I mean you know just I
guess
do whatever you think you should do you
know it's very distinct in its voice you
know which I think Diablo Cody has kind
of made her you know her Hallmark in a
way but I don't think anybody knew who
she was when you know that script came
out of nowhere and she just kind of
wrote it in like a sandwich shop or
something and really carved this voice
you know out of nothing and um I think
actually she had a Blog that she was
kind of a little famous for at the time
but um yeah reading it for the first
time that's just the thing that really
knocks you out is kind of the voice the
voice of it I think I'm in love with you
you can meet his friends
no
I mean for real
because you're like
the coolest person I've ever met and and
you don't even have to try you know
I try really hard actually I remember
when the movie came out there was some
like I don't know promotional effort
that involved a bunch of guys dressed in
those track uh
suits or the running you know outfit and
like running around Hollywood in a
cluster which was just you know kind of
funny and uncanny
Nick and Nora's Infinite Playlist
the thing that most drew me to it was um
Pete solid who directed it um and he had
made this like incredible movie raising
Victor Vargas it was like stunningly
great that movie and just wanted to do
anything with him and then there was an
amazing script by Laureen scaffaria who
um
yeah had adapted from a book but did
this great job with with the script so
it just felt like it was going to be
good so that's it Chris that's the
breakup mix 10 songs from my broken
that's not even real
can we go straight to laughing about
this I have to be it was like a month or
longer of of night shoots which is you
know strange like
strange biological experience sleeping
with the Sun up and garbage trucks going
by in life outside your window and not
sleeping very well but I was I think 19
when I made that movie and having the
greatest time because we would wrap it
like 6 a.m and then we would go get soup
at veselka or go you know hang out
honestly it's probably the reason I live
in New York today because I really fell
in love with the city and the feeling of
just wandering through it and how alive
it is and how generous it is as far as
like a texture of life you're just
there's just always something of
Interest happening all over the place
sometimes you have to guard yourself
against it it can be a lot but like I
was just so drawn I got this hey what's
up friend how you doing I got I was just
gonna go in there you walked right in
your dinner little bird I didn't mean to
him sorry he's like a little Canary and
skinny jeans huh well I was gonna go in
there just to look for my friend oh you
got friends right here me and
Switzerland are here for you baby hey
thanks for coming by let me ask you a
question you ever hook up with the dog
but no what like a dog like a pet no I
don't it's not worth it I like you so
much I've been running away with that
era there's like there was like a studio
independent movie genre almost where
they weren't really independent I mean
you know they were financed by Studios
and they would cost a lot of money but
they sort of like are labeled
independent they're sort of a flavor
like a lane that they found a genre that
or something it seems like it's gone I
mean it seems like it's an era that
where the like that model doesn't work
anymore at like where movies being made
at that level or at that budget that
aren't you know superhero movies or
something that will guaranteed to have
an audience you know it just seems like
this sort of relic of that time I'm not
sure if it'll come back but like a 10
million dollar movie or something you
know which used to be kind of normal to
get made and now now I don't think
they're being made anymore I think you
either make now like a very small movie
that we can go make like with this grill
or um you know a giant movie it's a
little weird it's changed
This Is the End
hey is this coke smell funny
I've never done cocaine dude
well you did the best possible for
your first time because that's good I'm
not sure whose idea it was I guess it
was Seth and Evan and you know the thing
that like was was hugely beneficial for
me on that movie was that I I kind of
kind of came in late they had been
shooting and they had been shooting that
house party sequence in particular for
you know at least like a week or so
before before I got in I kind of had to
come in late because I was just
finishing another job so when I got
there they like filled me in on
what everybody had been saying about me
they had all been kind of describing me
creating a character really for me to
like step into and so they told me all
that which was hilarious and then it was
really just like all there for me I just
have to live up to what they're saying I
have to be
weird
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's not cool
man up Jason we're playing the game
man
yeah I mean she definitely hit me yeah
um but I really I wanted that you know I
mean I I think it's a lot funnier and a
lot more convincing I mean a fake slap
just doesn't look good so she hit me
hard I mean yeah she really sent me
flying and it was great and now it's uh
on film forever this pain that I
experienced
[Music]
who's here
it's Wally we're so excited he came in
unannounced
see you again while we
it's good to see you too Sheriff Truman
as you know your brother Harry S Truman
is my godfather
well the full story actually is that I
met David Lynch I don't know a year or
two earlier because I had done a
transcendental meditation course where
you go to the center they teach you how
to do it they give you your Mantra you
go for like an hour over four days they
just kind of make sure you've got a
handle on it and um the fourth day when
I was leaving I was with a few friends
of mine this woman just appeared and she
was a young woman she said my name is
pookie I work with David Lynch
would you guys like to meditate with
David sometime and we were like what
what do you mean that's I mean just
unbelievable
invitation
and you know came out of outer space and
we were like that's insane Lord can't
even say how profoundly um important he
is to uh to me I got there first I was
the first one there I went up and met
David alone for like five minutes
and uh he was just so sweet I was like
what is this going to be like I'm coming
to his home is he going to be annoyed is
he just
kind of eye rollingly allotting this
time to us because someone convinced him
to what is the situation but he was so
welcoming
so warm so happy that we were there it
was the four of us and we sat in this
like art studio at the back of his house
and meditated with him and um talked for
a while a friend of mine who was there
Jocelyn was about to make her first film
and just had questions for him like do
you have any advice on directing and he
gave great advice very practical advice
and that felt like it was going to be it
you know and I was like grateful to ever
have met him and then a few years later
got this invitation to come work with
him on this show
for you know one day I think I was on
that set for like two hours Toms and
that was just like the greatest
experience
I've crisscrossed this great land of
ours
countless times
I hold the map of it here in my heart
next to the joyful memories of the
Carefree days I spent
as a young boy
you know that was just it was very
specifically written it was a monologue
they said
in the script I think how I was dressed
and
then I speak like Marlon Brando that was
basically all
that was provided to me and so I
prepared myself and wanted to show up
completely prepared and but but open to
whatever he would want to adjust or do
or whatever but we hardly talked about
it on set like we did it a couple times
he came over I think mostly he gave me
notes on like some of the punctuations
in the in the monologue like really hit
that comma or whatever you know small
things like that shaping the like the
rhythm of it and um but just and then
just like very supportive and we did it
just a few times and it was done and uh
I really wish I could have spent much
more time working with them because it
was really it's really a joy
the adults
it is sort of a very mysterious
character as written because um
a lot is withheld the ambiguity actually
is sort of with the driving force of the
story is actually the ambiguity that's
happening between the characters this
distance this gulf that's happening
between them but that was I think what
was compelling to me about reading the
script actually is everything that's
living in the darkness of the characters
and of their history and that we don't
know and the little pieces that we do
see are what we have to draw our
conclusions from
I have a hand yeah
any good I think it's good
yeah I have a ham I don't have the nuts
or anything
I played poker you know before doing the
movie I used to play in a home game a
weekly home game at my friend's house
which
the game still stands but I don't live
in Los Angeles anymore but they still
play I used to love playing just you
know just for the social aspect of it
just to be there you know joke around
and I would kind of just throw my money
away and lose I would lose you know and
then there are some people that were
playing at a different level that seemed
to have like a understanding of the game
and the fundamentals of it and so I knew
that they were playing on a different
level than me but I was never really too
curious to to go deeper with it until I
got cast in Molly's game and then I
thought maybe I should read a book a
poker book and see what they know that I
don't know there's something going on
that I don't know but maybe I should
just get interested in it and then once
I did I found it like so bottomlessly
fascinating I really love poker to this
day I love playing it I have kind of
Seasons where I'm good at it and then
other times when I'm just terrible and
just can't get a handle on it but it's
fun